again and again Boris Johnson told the
public and Parliament that in here they
followed the rules but his investigators
were told by a number 10 Insider just
how untrue that was parties and
end-of-week Gatherings all continued as
normal this was all part of a wider
culture of not adhering to any rules
number 10 was like an island oasis of
normality damning testimony about the
culture inside Boris Johnson's Downing
Street revealed by a junior number 10
official blowing the whistle to this
committee they said that even though
they set the rules for the rest of the
country they were slow to be enforced
inside number 10 the only nod to the
rules was a warning to be mindful of the
cameras on the way out it was all they
said a pantomime this the most notorious
example of that culture Boris Johnson in
November 2020 during a lockdown
surrounded by alcohol the committee not
buying his explanation even now after
the publication of this report Boris
Johnson maintained that he had to go to
leaving dues in number 10 to boost
morale but the committee disagrees they
say that the covert rules and guidance
at the time did not allow a socially and
distance event to proceed purely for the
purposes of maintaining staff morale and
this would have been clear to Mr Johnson
it was a pattern of behavior the report
says the then prime minister standing in
the Commons making statements he must
have known were false all guidance was
followed uh completely during number 10
whatever happened the guidance was
followed and the rules were followed at
all times I believe that the events in
question were within the guidance and
were within the rules and I came to this
house and said in all sincerity that the
rules and guidance would be followed at
all times that was four of the eight
times the committee thought that Boris
Johnson had misled Parliament and after
trawling through mountains of evidence
this is the Crux of the argument that
they reached at the end they say they
found it highly unlikely that the former
prime minister could have believed the
assertions he made to the Commons at the
time that he was making them many
aspects of Mr Johnson's defense are not
credible taken together they form
sufficient basis for a conclusion that
he intended to mislead deliberate
deception combined with a campaign of
intimidation against the committee
leaving this former prime minister
facing an unprecedented punishment
simcote Sky News